[Music]  the Internet is obsessed with your  picture working out in heels in the gym  with Gunnar Peterson do you work out in  heel this is not the first time that  I've worked at any yield like I remember  the first time I did this on cribs and  everyone was like hopefully cuz she's  with you go to duping I'm like like I'm  being serious and then I was just like  let me just do this for laps and you  know I don't know I don't know if they  took it seriously or whatever  I went work I went to work out with can  we work out in heels together can we  have a workout yells no man and it's  actually good for the walls  I believe Rihanna sweeten her excitement  she said I made those shoes did you see  her reaction I did and I love her I  think she's beautiful and amazing and  she's yeah and I love I love her shoes I  love what I love those moments I do you  have you can we get a Mariah Brianna  collaboration perhaps I mean I love her  [Music]  you